eu vou falar sobre gentrificação não é
um tema que está muito em voga hoje em
dia e muita gente ouve falar sobre isso
hum e antes disso eu queria contar um
pouco como eu entrei em contato com essa
o que é gente fica assim como entrei em
contato com esse conceito é que eu vou
ter que voltar só um pouquinho mas ela
que você rápido aqui na minha trajetória
eu voltar pra falar um pouquinho quando
eu saí da minha graduação e
pós-graduação de publicidade mas eu saí
com uma vontade e um desejo acadêmico
diferente do que isso da sua comunicação
não estava obcecado pela idéia de como
as pessoas se relacionam com espaços né
que faz as pessoas irem para um espaço
ficarem dentro de um espaço e se
relacionarem com ele
então comecei a procurar a partir daí há
exemplos em são paulo de ruas e espaços
que tivessem uma relação interessante e
aí eu me deparei com uma rua a antiga
conhecida minha que era robusta que
tinha uma relação diferente né
inicialmente o que me interessava na rua
augusta era isso né a brincadeira que a
festa é na verdade por cinco motivos não
acadêmicos não interessava também pela
rua mas existiam várias outras coisas
acadêmicas ali que eu achava muito
interessante e legal de conversar né
a primeira coisa até lhe o exemplo do
barulho é tão ele mostra muito isso é o
como as pessoas em uma cidade aonde
hegemonia do espaço privado prevaleciam
principalmente no lazer é você tinha uma
rua onde as pessoas se divertiam no
espaço ela se vestir um espaço público é
normalmente falar se estou indo a
robusta não tô indo pra aquela balada
robusta ou aquele espaço dentro da li eu
tô indo pra me divertir na rua estavam
na calçada ocupando aquele espaço se
apropriando aquele espaço de uma forma
diferente né
o segundo ponto que também dá pra ver
ali mas andando pela roubos vão ter
muito mais é a heterogeneidade daquele
espaço né
não era só um tipo de pessoa que existia
ali naquela rua mas servia de diversos
tipos desde o executivo
anton putilo rap ao lado dele ali até a
prostituta trabalhando à noite né
desde jovem hipster ali no bar do netão
por exemplo aqui curtindo até você via
um mendigo ou mesmo guez antes que rege
todos convivendo ali dentro daquele
espaço não necessariamente uma forma
sempre boa mas ele estava convidando
existindo naquele espaço né
o terceiro ponto é a própria
característica arquitetônica espacial
dessa rua né ela era uma profusão de
arquitetura tinha tanto desde prédios
antigos e alguma criatura bem antiga até
prédios novos pede que a gente nunca
prestou atenção né ali então ela está
grande profusão arquitetônica e de
espaços né
até como uma quando massimo canevacci em
antropólogos veio pra para o brasil e
olhou e vai analisar são paulo ele falou
da rua e falou gente essa expressão mais
pura e suja do que é são paulo né
você tinha um sincretismo de coisas e
diversas coisas acontecendo ali que dava
essa característica para elas
aí pronto eu achei o meu tema de
mestrado era isso que eu queria entender
que queria entender o que essas
características o porquê que aquelas
pessoas iam para aquela rua e fazia
essas cartas que o tanto valorizavam
dessa rua o que aconteceu ao longo do
tempo em que comecei a treinar mestrado
na fao para poder entender mas isso
quando eu comecei a me aprofundar nesse
assunto eu percebi que muitas dessas
características que valorizavam na rua
elas estavam se perdendo ao longo do
tempo muitas coisas que eu contei pra
vocês que me interessava nela estavam
acabando né eu vou contar um pouquinho
do que essas coisas estavam acabando com
a gente chegar depois
nesse conceito eu quero apresentar a
primeira coisa é o próprio espaço estava
mudando né com a mancha do lazer noturno
a partir de 2005 que se intensifica lá a
gente começa a ver uma valorização do
espaço imobiliário o valor do aluguel
sobe os serviços começam a ser
substituídos e direcionados a uma ou
outra pessoa e o próprio espaço mesmo a
própria casa os casarões que existiam lá
o prédio que existia lá começam a ser
trocados substituídos por uma outra
forma de ocupação
um exemplo claro disso é esse casarão
nadando pela de queiroz que é do major
antônio teles de 1903 né ele entrou num
processo de tombamento mas acabou não
sendo tombado e ali jan por volta de
2011 2012 ele foi destruído e deu origem
a um prédio residencial né que tinha
essa promessa de estar numa rua super
multi cultural mas trazia a grande
maioria dos serviços para dentro deles
não sabem sair para comer que tinha sua
varanda gourmet de dentro
então você tinha esse tipo de ocupação e
uma outra coisa interessante até o
próprio vegas que era um dos das casas
noturnas que chamou a atenção pra lá e
as pessoas começaram a freqüentar a rua
até a partir desta casa noturna fechou
por causa da especulação imobiliária até
o próprio facundo guerra quando ele fez
o post de fechamento da guerra ele
sinalizou isso que ele teve que a casa
sair do vegas teve que sair da globo usa
porque estava muito caro e essa cidade
de são paulo ela não comporta ela não
comporta esses estabelecimentos menores
sempre tem essa lógica e imobiliária
milionária que acontece né mas isso é
bem engraçado que até o próprio
estabelecimento que trouxe lhe trouxe
essa classe média alta para a rua acabou
também fechando o conta disso o outro
caso é a questão da heterogeneidade
tanto que um exemplo
o engraçado pra te falar um pouco sobre
isso mas é a questão de com que cada vez
mais estava tomando a rua muito mais
homogênea né
as pessoas com menos menor ao social ou
de classe social menor estavam saindo da
rua né e falam da prostituta que era um
símbolo da rua augusta muito forte muito
dessa atração que era a rua se dava por
conta dessa instituição na rua que tinha
lá esse clima que a gente tinha ali ela
também acabou saindo e esse eu analisei
no mestrado os anúncios e matérias
jornalísticas a partir do jornal 'el
para entender como foram as mudanças eu
acho que a travesti eduardo ela conta
uma história pra gente do que aconteceu
ali na rua com a questão da prostituição
né
em 2001 ela anunciava ali como modelo
para pessoas de bom gosto o atendimento
na rua augusta né
já em 2008 2009 ela perdeu o corpo
modelo mas ela continua atendendo na ro
ou está nela e ela continua pessoas vão
gostar augusta centro que aconteceu em
a travesti eduardo ela sai da rua
augusta e vai pra próxima augusta e
ainda sinaliza local com discrição pra
ela porque que aconteceu ali no momento
em que a rua começou a ficar muito mais
votado e cheia de gente e freqüentando
essa prostituta que precisava da
descrição para vender os seus serviços
pararem ali perdeu o seu lugar é o cara
não ia parar ali o executivo nem para
pegar um prostituto filho dele estava se
divertindo na rua né
então o que acontece essas duas
começaram a sair
a andada própria rua e para as
localidades próximas a elas e depois
posteriormente acabaram saindo como
completa ea história da travesti eduardo
é um pouco dessa você relata hoje mas na
china que não deve dar entrada no
butantan e agora outra coisa lembra
daquela foto que eu trouxe que era uma
das coisas que mais me atraiu para o
barulho é tão ali que era um tinha
aquelas festas na rua eu tirei uma foto
também ali no meu estado do mesmo lugar
mais ou menos no mesmo horário e no
mesmo dia muito para mostrar um pouco do
que aconteceu com esse espaço
senti um espaço de pessoas ficavam na
verdade uma balada lá dentro mas também
bebia na rua estavam na rua aproveitando
com a a valorização imobiliária
construção desse prédio aqui ó que vocês
estão vendo tobi se um muro gigante
destrói-se lugar
a rua fica mal iluminada e cada vez mais
desértica né então você vê até ficar até
mais difícil o mais que está mais vazio
fica até mais perigoso a sensação de de
perigo muito maior que aconteceu eu não
sabia mas nesse tempo todo que eu estava
fazendo mestrado que isso estava
acontecendo quando tinha eleito
eu estava vendo um processo que era o
processo de gentrificação né e aí quando
eu conheci o termo foi nossa isso
explica muito o que está acontecendo eu
vou contar um pouquinho pra vocês que
esta gente ficar são e o que aconteceu
realmente com a rua augusta para falar
sobre identificação e trouxe a primeira
vez que o termo foi usado a
academicamente na história né
foi pela rua glass em 64 uma socióloga
inglesa que ela explica o que a gente
ficar são em termos bem simples que ela
fala na verdade o que aconteceu é a
substituição de uma classe social mais
favorecido então os operários por uma
classe média média alta amplo naquele
espaço e num processo em que acaba sendo
muito mais rápido em pouco tempo então
aquele bairro operário virar um bairro
de classe média média alta
então o conceito gente da gente ficar
são muito simples é exatamente isso é a
substituição de pessoas de uma classe
social normalmente menor ou de um aval
social menor uru outras normalmente já o
social maior e de uma classe superior
mas atrás de um conceito simples o que
eu percebi é que
existia uma teia de processos de uma
complexidade muito maior
o conceito parece simples mas o que leva
ele é muito complicado é uma teia de
relações de pessoas espaços processos
maiores que acabam originando a gente
ficar são eu acho que é uma boa forma de
tentar entender o que a gente ficar são
a metáfora é quando a gente compara com
um iceberg
tá o sbt a gente sempre aponta a gente
percebe que se deve falar que a gente vê
aquela ponta em cima do mar mas embaixo
dele tem uma bloco de gelo muito maior e
é isso que torna o perigo maior desse
iceberg né
com a identificação é a mesma coisa a
gente só percebe a identificação quando
a gente vê o prédio caindo
a gente fala curtas local danificado
olha isso tirar aquela casinha ou aquele
serviço que eu estava ali mas a
identificação começou muito antes né
e ela é muito mais perigosa porque ela é
uma teia de processo que aconteceram
antes que a gente nem percebia mas
estava acontecendo e o perigo maior é
que ela dá a sensação de que é natural
que é uma coisa que acontece é do
capitalismo mesmo isso acontece isso é
um processo de oferta e demanda que
sempre acontece e não é né
a justificação na verdade é um processo
que é feito por pessoas evitem ações
tanto ativas e conscientes quanto ações
inconscientes que acontece naquele
espaço e fazem a expulsão daquelas
pessoas daquele espaço né
outra coisa interessante identificação é
que ela não acontece só em são paulo ou
no brasil ela acontece no mundo inteiro
e principalmente em cidades onde a gente
vê as disparidades sociais e as classes
sociais
disputando espaços né e se o até a
disparidade social ela se reflete muito
nessa luta mesmo por espaços
qualificados perto do trabalho espaços
de lazer e é por isso que as cidades
globais acabam se tornando esse símbolo
da gente ficar são né eu acho até que a
palavra luta uma palavra que explica
muito bem o que a gente explicação eu
quando a gente vai tentar entender o
conceito a gente ficar só na verdade é
uma guerra fria que acontece por espaço
né aonde a arma em que é usada é o
acesso né na verdade restringindo o
acesso de uma forma clara por exemplo
colocando aquele muro destruindo aquele
espaço restringindo o acesso àquelas
pessoas aquele espaço ou
uma forma não tão clara e mais obscura
como por exemplo aumentando o valor da
cerveja aumentando o valor do imóvel
colocando uma outra um outro grupo de
interesse dentro daquele espaço com uma
outra música para tocar aqui no
encerramento daquelas pessoas gostam
isso você tá assim gente ficando né
então é um pouco isso que a
identificação e pra gente tentar
entender o que tem embaixo do iceberg ou
trouxe sete pontos importantes a gente
tentar desmistificar o que a gente ouve
falar de identificação acredita que é
natural e não vê tá eu vou falar deles
bem rapidinho pra vocês
o primeiro deles é que a gente ficar são
é sim uma ação consciente de expulsão e
de limpeza social né
ela acontece ela tem um órgão uma um uma
pessoa um organismo que está
conscientemente tirando aquelas pessoas
de lá seja ele o governo a imobiliária
ou qualquer outro estabelecimento tá a
polícia por exemplo é um dos grandes
agentes da gente ficar são nesse sentido
né
o que aconteceu na praça roosevelt acho
bem emblemático por isso né
uma praça que foi reformada visando um
novo público visando uma revitalização
entre aspas sair daquela região e aí
quando os skatistas começaram a utilizar
aquela praça eles foram expulsos pela
polícia até o vídeo está no youtube fala
muito sobre isso né como esse conflito
foi realmente agressivo né é um processo
de você não pode estar nesse espaço esse
espaço não é feito para você né
o segundo ponto é que ela não é
declarada ninguém falar tudo entre
ficando aqui agora é a hora da gente
ficar são né
as pessoas na verdade disfarça a esse
discurso de outras
o discursos mais aparentemente positivos
né
então você ouve muito termo
revitalização requalificação e
apropriação do espaço ea pergunta que a
gente tem sempre que fazer com a gente
vê esse termo para ver se é real é pra
quem revitalização para quem tem
qualificação para a can porque na grande
maioria dos casos com esta pergunta
gente descobre que aquilo ali está
mascarando a gente ficar são porque por
exemplo porto maravilha a revitalização
e requalificação que foi feita lá não é
para as pessoas que moram em volta do
porto o que moram naquela região do
porto que já freqüentam ali
pensando numa outra classe num outro
grupo social e um outro a inter é
assunto de interesse
o terceiro ponto é que ela pode até
valorizar o espaço no discurso mas na
prática ele destrói
eu acho isso muito importante assim o
caso da rua augusta é bem claro com isso
quando a rua augusta começa a virar esse
centro multicultural começa a chamar
atenção não só de são paulo do brasil e
do mundo
o que acontece é que os próprios
estabelecimentos e inclusive os
empreendimentos imobiliários começam a
utilizar dessa característica
multicultural o hype aí da rua augusta
com um discurso quando eles vêm eles
acabam destruindo e entrando no lugar de
muitos bares serviços de coisas que
faziam e deixavam heterogêneo aquela
região
né quando você faz um prédio augusto
augusta hype hype live em que fala que
você vai morar no centro cultural e tira
os estabelecimentos de lá e direciona
isso só por uma elite ou que tenha
acesso a esse prédio
você tá sendo entre ficando por mais que
você esteja valorizando a arte daquele
espaço
no fim você está destruindo aquela
cultura o quarto ponto é que o hype
custa caro né então apropriação de
vanguardas artísticas do jovem de tudo
isso que a gente vê em diversos lugares
do mundo por exemplo william acabam
sendo o primeiro passo para a elitização
né
a elite ela não vai a parte média alta
normalmente tradicionalmente ela não
entra num espaço mais pobre um espaço
desvalorizado na opinião dela se
apropria ele né
a vanguarda artística que tem um pouco
menos de dinheiro mas que procura
espaços novos para se apropriar acaba
entrando moldando o espaço a partir dos
serviços de coisas voltadas pra eles e
assim preparando o terreno ali por uma
elitização então é quase muito cruel
quando a gente vê esta frase artes eo
estilo livre mas é exatamente isso né
o artista entra e no final a gente acaba
vendo um processo de até expulsão de si
próprio ano que o artista jovem
uma outra coisa que na rua augusta
também é muito clara mas no mundo
inteiro acontece isso é que o azera
urbano ele serve como um acelerador de
identificação né porque porque se você
for pensar a questão imobiliária quando
vou trocar por exemplo vou destruir
aquele prédio colocar outro prédio
demora muito mais
pensando até em anos em tempo o lazer é
muito mais orgânico muito mais fluido e
muito mais fácil de você mudar você
mudar o preço da cerveja de um mês para
o outro o da o preço da balada pra
entrar de um mês para o outro é mais é
muito mais fácil muito mais rápido do
que você trocar as pessoas que existia
naquele espaço você destruir aquele
espaço com colocar outro em cima então
muito do lazer
isso é uma das coisas mais tristes em
que eu ia vendo esse ano no estado é que
era isso lazer a partir de 2005 até a
entrada do vegas acabou acelerando muita
gente ficar são e em 4 anos e 5 anos
ainda tinha uma rua completamente
diferente
no caso de henrique em londres por
exemplo 319% valor o valor do imóvel
subiu naquela rua ou de 1.199 até 2012 é
um absurdo o sexto ponto é que a gente
ficar são é também fruto da uma lógica
de consumismo de espaço que a gente tem
né a gente não se contenta em consumir
somente aquilo a que ele fazer aquilo
que até aí a gente na rua que quer fazer
tudo ela né ea rua augusta é um exemplo
disse eu quero ir desde o cabeleireiro
ali ó no retrô até como a padaria
inglesa que se instalou ali como o
pãozinho de manhã quer fazer tudo
naquele espaço né e isso acaba
aumentando e aumentando a oferta é
aumentando a demanda aí pra mim e poder
ter um processo simplificado acontecendo
e uma elitização do espaço que você tem
pessoas com muita vontade de fazer tudo
daquele espaço e consumir ele a exaustão
do sétimo ponto última que iria trazer é
que gentrificação não é uma coisa só de
gente grande não é só uma coisa de
mobiliário de governo né
somos todos gente ficar dores né no
momento em que eu vou na rua augusta e
eu aceito pagar r$5 há mais três reais a
mais uma cerveja de entrar naquele lugar
de que eu quero morar naquele espaço
super legal e multicultural perto do
centro mas aí eu vou lá e pago um
aluguel que seria muito acessível para
outra classe eu tô sendo identificador
tá e aí que foi que caiu a ficha uma
faixa muito triste pra mim que no
momento em que eu fui tentar entender as
características da rua augusta eu
gostava muito dela e me aprofundar
eu prefiro me percebi como identificador
né
fui eu que ajudei até
um pouco com aquela característica que
eu gostava na rua augusto e sem perceber
né
só que o que mudou agora eu acho que é
isso que é o ponto importante é que
comecei a ter consciência
comecei a perceber que aquele o lazer
que estava tendo aquela freqüência que
estava naquela rua foi prejudicial sim
né e o comércio vê acontecendo no mundo
todo é o nascimento de uma consciência
mais coletivo a gente começou a discutir
de identificação começou a protestar
contra a identificação e começou a
perceber essa questão acontecendo
claro que é muito mais difícil de
combater porque só com o discurso mas eu
acredito que com um discurso quando a
gente é reflexo de uma coisa que a gente
percebe que a gente está fazendo uma
coisa a gente abre espaço para uma ação
e uma transformação
então o que eu queria acabar esse papo
essa conversa com vocês agora é desse
sonho mesmo como que a gente consegue
apropriar de uma cultura diferente se
apropriar de um espaço que não
necessariamente está feito pra gente sem
destruir aquela cultura que existia ali
tem destruir aquela certeza que a gente
tanto valorizavam nesse espaço e isso é
uma coisa que se eu tivesse resposta
junto eu falava mas é uma coisa que eu
queria trazer como discussão que a gente
pensa daqui pra frente
obrigado